Speaker 1: Welcome everybody.
We're starting today with two stories that
are going to upset a bunch of people in my
audience, and that's OK.
One is about Jordan Peterson, which we will
get to.
The first is about Whoopi Goldberg.
Many of you wrote to me about Whoopi Goldberg
statements on The View, where she is one of
a number of co-hosts about the Holocaust and
race and Jewish people.
And as I was preparing a story about this
news broke that Whoopi Goldberg indeed has
now been suspended for two weeks by The View
because of her comments about the Holocaust.
Now I'm just going to give you my interpretation
of what she said, and I'm going to explain
to you why what she said is so problematic
and what the main thrust of what Whoopi said
on The View is that the Holocaust is not about
race or was not about race, and there's really
two or three different layers of confusion
here, which I'm going to try to pick apart.
And there's a ton of people who still don't
understand the concept of Judaism as a race,
saying, Well, hold a Judaism's or religion.
It's not really a race.
And the part that makes this segment difficult
is that unfortunately, I mean, listen, I expect
out, out and out anti-Semitism from the right.
I get it all the time.
Soros funds, you go back to Israel, a place
I've been once and I have no real connection
to.
You know, all these different things.
I expect that from the right.
But on the left, there's a different thing
that goes on.
And we saw it with the Women's March, where,
for example, the Women's March from from several
years ago now they didn't want leadership,
didn't want Jewish women involved on the board
because Jewish women were seen as privileged
whites rather than a historically discriminated
minority group.
And inbuilt in that are all sorts of biases
and prejudices that only reinforce anti-Semitic
tropes.
And so the Left has a problem with this, too.
I don't care if you don't like hearing that,
I'm going to call it out on both sides.
So let's just jump into the clip and I'm going
to try rather than pre explain.
Let's just look at this piece by piece.
OK, let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Well, also, if you're going to
do this, then let's be truthful about it because
the Holocaust isn't about race.
No, no.
It's not about me.
Know it's about race, but it's not about race.
It's not about race.
Is it about because it's about man's inhumanity
to man?
That's what it's about.
But it's about white supremacy.
Well, it's not about race, but these are two
white groups of people.
Without it, we have a black victim is white.
And then what?
You're missing the point, you're missing the
point.
The minute you turn it into race, it goes
down this alley.
Let's talk about it for what it is.
It's how people treat each other.
It's a problem.
It doesn't matter if you're black or white
because black white Jews.
Speaker 1: And of course, it does matter if
the people carrying out the Holocaust believe
they're doing it along racial lines because
they see Jews as a different race, which we
will get to.
Speaker 2: It's everybody eats each other.
So is it if you're uncomfortable, if you hear
about mouse, should you be worried?
Should your child say, Oh my god, I'm OK?
Speaker 1: And then in another clip again,
she says the Holocaust is white people doing
stuff to white people.
Speaker 2: And in Tennessee school pull the
graphic novel mouse out of their lessons on
the Holocaust because it contains some nudity
and some bad language.
Personally, I'm shocked because, you know,
given the story of mass, I'm I'm surprised
that that's what that's what made you uncomfortable.
The fact that there was some nudity and I
mean, it's it's about the Holocaust, the killing
of six million people.
But that didn't that didn't bother you.
But the naked, I'm not sure that they don't
use the naked part as a kind of a canard to
throw you off from the fact that they may
buy history.
That makes me look bad.
Well, why this is why people doing it to why?
Yeah, so
Speaker 1: so there is that same idea, white
people doing it to white people.
So here's the thing.
First of all, there's this really funny thing
when it comes to Judaism, where you've got
the anti-Semitic right and white nationalists
who say Jews are not white Jews are a different
race.
I've had Richard Spencer, the white nationalist,
tell me Jews are not European.
They're not.
They're not what he is, right?
Jews definitely are not white.
Are among some on the left, you have the view
that Jews are white with the white privilege
that comes with being white.
Jews are not minorities, they're just privileged
white people.
And of course, this is where the concept of
white passing comes up.
And the truth is that while Ashkenazi Jews
are absolutely white passing, there's lots
of other Jews Sephardic Jews, Mizrahi Jews
who are not white passing.
But that's not even really what this is about.
There's not one right answer, but there kind
of is.
If you take the view that we're all one race,
there is no race, right?
Like, that's a view that some people take
now.
There's academic circles where we're all just
the human race.
OK, if that's the case, then this is all meaningless,
right?
Like if the view we're taking is there's race
is not a thing.
Ethnicity is not a thing, then there's no
black people and there's no white people,
and there's fine if we accept that there are
racial and ethnic groups.
OK, right?
So like if that's a conversation, if we want
to talk about humans in that context, Jews
are an ethnic group.
When I do my ancestry or 23 and me or whatever,
it says, Oh, your ethnicity is 100 percent
Ashkenazi Jewish.
If I convert to Christianity religiously,
I'm still 100 percent Ashkenazi Jewish.
And the origin of this confusion is that Jews
are an ethno religious group.
Now, sometimes people like to say that's a
special pleading.
There's no other ethno religious group it's
made up.
No, actually, there's tons of ethno religious
groups.
You're just not familiar with them.
The Copts in Egypt are an ethno religious
group.
The Yazidi people of Iraq are an ethno religious
group, which means what?
Yazidi Iraqis are an ethnic group.
And I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly
Yazidis or Yazidis them is also a religion.
You can quit being a religious Yazidi.
You would still be ethnically Yazidi.
You might not have heard of that.
And so sometimes people say, no, this is something
that's only it only exists with Jews.
It doesn't.
That's not true.
Separately, there are also sort of bad faith
people who pretend not to understand this,
who just like to attack Jews is privileged
and not worthy of our consideration.
Despite being at the top when you look at
religiously based hate crimes in the United
States.
Jews are always either at the top or almost
there in terms of being the victims of religiously
oriented hate crimes and sometimes the perceived
whiteness of Ashkenazi Jews is used as a means
to write off anti-Semitism.
And it was very ugly.
It was done in a very ugly way with the Women's
March of a couple years ago.
So that is Whoopi Goldberg is just wrong.
Now, in terms of her being suspended, I just
don't know.
With all of these about every time we talk
about suspensions, I have no idea what's appropriate
or what's not.
What I want to also mention is the suspension
of Whoopi Goldberg is furthering anti-Semitic
tropes, and you can you can probably imagine
why.
Whoopi Goldberg, suspended for her comments
about the Holocaust is proof to those who
want to talk about Jewish control of media
to say the Jews got her, the Jews who control
Hollywood and control the view, they got Whoopi
Goldberg.
And it just so so I'm not saying the suspension
is or isn't appropriate, but.
For people who want, you know, when all you
have is a hammer, everything looks like a
nail.
And so the same people who liked many of the
same people who like to appease comments are
now saying her suspension is proof.
Of that conspiracy of Jews to control Hollywood,
which we've talked about many times before,
so another one of these ugly incidents, and
I'm curious to hear what you think about it.